The last class of drugs we're going to discuss are the hallucinogens, or
psychedelics. These drugs can erratically distort the way a person perceives.
In addition, it can change the way they think, as well as the way they feel.
Sometimes when people take these substances, they can experience great fear or
anxiety. But in some cases, they say that it changes the way they view the
world. In addition, we see that people can experience synesthesia, and this is
a crossing over of the senses. For example, a person may hear colors or taste
sounds. In addition, LSD can bring back long-lost memories and some people
report a dying of the ego while taking this drug. Now, it's no doubt that some
people have experienced troublesome or even a frightening experiences from
taking hallucinogenic substances. And there's some research to support the idea
that one of these agents can act as an epigenetic agent and turn on the gene
that codes for mental illnesses, such as schizophrenia. Therefore, some major
caution for some people using hallucinogenic substances. Now, LSD has its
effect at the serotonin receptor and we see that psilocybin or magic mushrooms
also affect the serotonin receptor system however, not to the same degree as
LSD. Psilocybin can produce changes in perception and cognition as well. In
fact, some people have said that LSD demands introspection whereas as
psilocybin invites it.